we already know we're not going to get
the annual huge
fireworks display over the strip this
new year's eve
yeah the fireworks on the roof of the
plaza hotel downtown will be the only
show in the sky this year
and our ted florendo has a preview of
the pyrotechnics
hi everyone ted florent here on top of
the plaza hotel and casino and the
reason i'm here is because
this is where i'm going to be on new
year's eve as we welcome in 2021
with some of the biggest fireworks in
las vegas joining us live now
is nathan tanner he's the pyrotechnic
director for those fireworks here at the
plaza hotel nathan thanks for joining us
here
how is this going to be different from
what we see typically
on the strip it's caesar's compared to
here well
the stuff you guys see usually on the
strip is usually what they call a class
as a 1.3 g explosive meaning that those
type of shells have more
racks lift charges more of a more aerial
break and things like that
what we have here is closer to a g class
it's actually a close proximity and by
doing this we actually
throw in a lot of stage power as well
because our company itself we deal with
a lot of stage productions
so we have a big production with the 1.4
g
high explosive which is a close prox and
then we also mix in a lot of stage pyro
involved what's really cool is you like
to put this all together and make
an immersive experience is that correct
that's correct what i like to do is
because we have a stage pyro i do what
we call a 360 display
so meaning that instead of sitting there
looking in the distance seeing the
fireworks shows
i'll actually put the audience in the
middle of a show i'll still keep all the
uh
proper requirements needed for you know
fallout zones and everything else
but i liked it to where the audience is
fully emerged in the show where you're
looking behind you in front of you on
top of you
behind flames everything going off
around you instead of just sitting there
looking in the distance that's how i
like to create my shows this is going to
be a fantastic show to see
uh what's different this year from what
we've seen in years past well first of
all i'd like to
actually huge give a big thank you to
the plaza hotel for allowing us to be
part and working with such an amazing
team
we definitely wish we weren't going to
be the only show in town vegas isn't the
same without all of its talent
and over the top productions we are
currently thinking about others just
like us that are ready to get back to
work
for us it's about them and giving
everyone more reason to be hopeful
that's fantastic and we're excited for
you guys to get back to can you show us
a little bit about
where you plan to put these displays and
everything up here yeah i would love to
so up on the roof here we actually use
as much of a footprint that we can use
up here
if you see in the distance a lot of
these empty spots we're going to have
pyro laid out over here
we're going to pilot it over to my left
we're going to have pyro down on the
lower side of the plaza
and down on the pool deck i'm going to
have some flame units with some close
prox
uh pyro as well that we use for example
for safe distances down below the pool
deck
so all the audiences around will be up
here we'll be over to the left you'll
have fire and all that stuff going on
and we are so excited about it thank you
nate the tanner appreciate it uh
with the uh pyrotechnic director with
the uh plaza hotel here he's gonna fire
off those fireworks
at midnight and the best part to all
this guys is yours truly
is gonna be the guy that's actually
going to hit the button
to light up those fireworks i hope i
don't screw this up remember warm up
oh i gotta warm up my finger i gotta
roll my finger alright
here at the plaza hotel casino i'm ted
florendo we'll see you on new year's eve
[Music]
you heard it here first folks 2020 isn't
over until
ted florento presses a button oh man
i'm sure it'll go just fine you can
watch the fireworks in our own countdown
to 2021 special
kicks off at nine o'clock on new year's
eve we'll run past midnight we'll bring
you all the celebrations across the
country
and we're also raising money for food
banks here in the valley
any money that you donate is going to
stay right here in las vegas
you can find more information over at
eight newsnow dot com